good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy
thursday hey jax how you doing i'm doing
good knowing that it's thursday it's
just an exciting day of the week i mean
it looks like it's not thursday but it's
the last day on earth i know we're not
recording at 10 pm you guys no it's just
like
raining i don't know why like the
dramatic dark sky but it's just raining
it's a gloomy day which i don't hate
though when i woke up this morning i
just
wanted
like it was it was one of the harder
ones it's confusing when you wake up so
dark but i'm supposed to go to the us
open today and it's like of course the
u.s opens been going on for weeks so
fabulous so fabulous like every summer
and i was like oh today's my day and i
wake up and i'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on what is going on so like do you
still go when it's raining
well they actually can't play tennis
like on those courts in the rain so it
might get rescheduled
would you want it to get rescheduled i
don't know like i want to go yeah but do
you want to go like this no under
thunder cloud no but like i brought like
me i wake up and i'm like oh my god my
whole day's ruined and i texted ryan i'm
like the weather he's like it'll clear
up it's fine it might clear up yeah but
if it's like if it's raining they won't
play they won't no i'm pretty sure like
i remember from tennis growing up like
you can't play in the rain on those
hardcores i'm gonna put the athletes in
danger no you know what it's really like
it's not yeah you know my favorite part
of maybe they cover it but i don't think
so you know my favorite part of the us
open is like
because u.s open obviously happens every
year in queens and i assume like all the
players stay in the city and you know
it's like u.s open time when you see
those lexus official us vehicles you
ever see those not really i mean i guess
lexus is like the major sponsor of the
us open and they have official u.s open
vehicles and i think it's the vehicles
that drive
players to the stadium i'm not sure
who's in the car but you i always see
them and they stay at um on 42nd street
you know when you go down park and you
go through that like weird thing that
hotel right there i think it's a hyatt
all the cars are lined up and it's just
like oh i do know that hotel it's like
christmas you know it's like the us open
is here the lexuses have arrived but i'm
just wanting to know like are there
coaches in those cars or like actual
players you're asking the wrong person
because it seems like you're the expert
on the cards you're they'd be like
talking the ball boys would be in there
i don't know like i just want to know
who's in there the windows are too you
should you should do some more research
and find out well i wanted to talk about
it just like somebody who works for
lexus we'll let you know just let me
know like i've always wondered when i
was a kid i always thought like the
players were in there but i'm like the
players are probably not going to drive
around in a car that says the players in
here you know like sponsored on the side
just a thought okay
i'll let you know what i find out please
do we're waiting with baited breath
exciting for you
that you're going to us open oh yeah i'm
excited yeah it's going to be a good
time well hopefully if i go
nice um there's like a lot of things
going on in the city it's just like a
like there's so much traffic it's you
know what it's been two years since we
had this time of year but it's fashion
week it's us open next week i guess it's
met gala which i guess they tied on to
fashion week that's a new thing for us
and then i don't even want to say these
words
but it's starting to feel like the time
of year
of the un general assembly okay so
that's funny that you said that my
doorman told me that the president was
in town which is why like my street was
so [ __ ] congested i'm like what is
going on you guys if the u.n general
assembly is in session like we won't be
in studio no when we were growing up
honestly like i don't even know what the
i don't know why i was like an 8th
grader who knew what the general
assembly was but it just turns the city
on its head every street is closed every
street is blocked like it's impossible
to get around outside it's like no but
you're right
that feeling in the air it is that time
the traffic is built did they not have
it last year definitely not it was
probably virtual or we weren't leaving
our houses so we didn't notice
yeah but i'm really i hadn't thought
about it but now i'm i'm oh no we need
to find out their schedule so that we
can plan accordingly because we can't do
what we oh my god it's impossible you
can't just like live your life as normal
when the u.n is in town
oh
no yeah
oh man i didn't even think of that i had
literally there's so many things i
forgot about because it didn't happen
last year like fashion week like yeah
i totally forgot that was the thing now
it's back it feels like
bigger and louder than ever
yeah it also feels like less cool than
ever it feels more um like relatable
accessible revolvey yeah you know
because that's what it is like revolve
came to fashion week as they should as
they should and they brought all these
like revolve influencers and like
everything else in the world like
revolve has taken over no totally just
yeah
it's not mercedes-benz fashion week it's
revolve fashion week and honestly like
that tracks that does check that's what
people are wearing that's the industry
yeah
so i mean i haven't really seen anything
that's really taken your breath away
except i ordered a coat last night that
i got a targeted ad for that was so
stunning and beautiful and there's not
that much i can get excited about right
now in the way of fashion because like
sweatpants are all that fits me right
now
um but this coat you guys i think i'm
gonna have to wear it on the show just
because it's like so
so fabulous are you buying clothes like
for your pregnant body or for like your
afterlife for me not after life like
after your for my pregnancy because i
what i'm not buying for next spring
right
so
that's why i'm not really buying
anything special except for this coat
because you know a coat you can cover a
belly with of course
so can we kylie's coat today
we'll be talking about kylie's coat
thank god we will be talking about
kylie's coat
okay well i really didn't do oh i
finished the erotic novel please share
with the class and i conducted an
experiment that i would like to share
with the class okay so the erotic novel
which was called what i can't remember
what was called it happens one summer
and the wrong title for the book yeah
it's just it's like a whatever title for
like an iconic love story it should be
called like the fisherman and the
socialite like yeah you know or like
something yeah like they could have done
more with like fish fishnet stocking
something like you know something yeah
um i couldn't even remember the title
because it's so doesn't even apply to
the book i didn't know it was summer
when it happened and i thought it was it
happened one weekend and i'm like which
weekend no i didn't where they went to
seattle
seattle seattle okay like the book was
so cute and like honestly even outside
of the erotica like the story line was
adorable like you're just rooting for
brendan and piper yes i know that those
are currently the names of the two main
characters [ __ ] [ __ ] up on bathroom
paradise but i'm talking about the two
main characters the protagonists in the
book we're currently talking about which
is called it happens one summer
so cute i loved the ending it was just
like an easy light read it didn't
require too much of me and i gave it
five stars because i really enjoyed
myself and you know what i wanted to do
afterwards but i forgot you know you
could search words like in kindle like i
just wanted to see how many times they
used the word
because towards the end like i was
losing track i first was one then two
and then three and then i lost count
after three
yeah i didn't think it was like that
many times because or maybe it was just
like after the first time where like it
just shocks you yeah then you become
desensitized that's very possible
well i'm so glad you liked it and i have
the same exact reaction like okay this
book is super
raunchalicious but it's a great book
that's why i recommend it to you that's
why i took this leap of faith and i did
a poll on my story not a poll but a
slidey scale of house if you've read
this book how spicy would you rank it
and a lot of people said and i saw it in
groups also that like it's not a 10 out
of 10 on a spy scale for them not for
people who read spicy books right like
50 shades
and other spicy books well i then was
like you know what i loved it so much
i'm like let me read the sequel
and i bought the sequel and i guess i
bought the wrong book because i didn't
recognize any of these characters names
and then i realized it was like just
another one of her books called fix her
up like about a remodeling
and honestly like it's really silly like
it's
it's not it it's not it like you know
where they lost me like i was trying to
be optimistic like it was courtney but i
honestly don't mind corniness in books
and you know where they lost me was like
this girl georgie who's the main
character who's just kind of like the
little sister who no one will take
seriously
um
as a profession she is a clown
at like kids parties and she loves it so
much she loves kids so much and honestly
i just thought it was such a weird kind
of like
character flaw that i just i decided not
to continue and yeah that's a little
strange you know so random someone's got
to be the clown but i know
uh there are other jobs if you love kids
so much like counselor teacher counselor
yeah professional counselor so it was
just bizarre but i spent the ten dollars
on the book so i was like let me give it
a chance and honestly i couldn't okay i
mean
that's fine there is the sequel to the
book i think it's called hook line and
sinker but it's about which would have
been a better name for the original
it's about the sister who
didn't resonate with me she didn't
resonate with me either because she was
just like annoying being like vinyl
vinyl records are like my life no like
being into vinyl records is not a
personality trait i completely agree
literally like all she said and whenever
she spoke was just like
recording no literally she spoke in
vinyl but
i was really interested in the storyline
between her and fox like if all four of
them ended up in westport like that
would be so cute yeah and she was such a
good sister like i didn't despise her
but like
she's not a girl i choose to hang out
with yeah i agree with that or read
about that's why i didn't read the
sequel um
so yeah beverly hills was on last night
it was it was okay it was good we have
it was good i've got a lot to
unpack me too in addition to the
fastback story it's like breaking news
as we sat our asses down here yesterday
like yeah so [ __ ] in a wings so let's
get right into it because we have some
exciting news to share
here are the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast
and today's episode is of course brought
to you by bruce
when you use bruce you guys there's
nothing better you're gonna get every
crevice
every corner
every plaque filled gap
clean with the brush the best electric
toothbrush on the market and the most
affordable some electric toothbrushes
can cost over two hundred dollars bruce
says no thank you ma'am they are
affordable and they work so great and
they're so aesthetically like stunning
they're gonna look great on your
bathroom counter the brush itself comes
with six unique modes to customize your
brushing experience the battery life
lasts four weeks it comes with a
magnetic charging stand and a compact
travel case they also offer a
subscription program so you never forget
to change your brush head again they'll
ship you a new replacement head every
six months so you're never stuck using a
worn down brush head the design is super
sleek their toothbrush has a modern
aesthetically pleasing design that comes
in trend drip excuse me trend driven
seasonal colors and it looks great on
your bathroom counter brush is the
unofficial official toothbrush of the
morning toast every toaster it's gotten
their brush and loved it and if you
haven't gotten it yet like you're
missing out but don't worry i have a
code for you you can get 15 off your
brush toothbrush kit
and the refill plan when you use the
promo code toast at bruce.com that's 15
off using the promo code toast at
brush.com
great also um claudia and i are twinning
today oh yeah i totally forgot i know we
can't even see ourselves but we're
twinning in our sprit society merch
because the sports society merch is
launching today at 12 p.m eastern time
at spritsociety.com they have the cutest
launch merch including these sweatshirts
which we obviously both chose the same
one thing to wear because like and also
we're wearing our shoes the same way and
socks yeah like just something cute
about us we're so huge we're so cute and
we didn't even plan it we also have crew
necks oh no that's already what we said
we have crew necks we also have t-shirts
dad hats and really the most sickening
reversible bucket hat actually have it
here i should grab it but um okay hold
on one sec really quite sickening stuff
uh just like great these sweatshirts are
so comfortable it's freezing in the
studio today like actually they're
trying to ice us out of here and we are
chilling in our sweatshirts oh you look
super cute which is so cute should i
leave it on we'll we'll leave it on for
a second and then flip it yeah okay so
here's the one
and you might think oh they're selling
two bucket hats a black and a white no
no
it's a twofer
it's a twofer which is so cool i've
never seen this before like why don't
you really like these for toast i don't
know should i wear those for the rest of
the dress yeah but i think i like it
better on the white
yeah i know the only problem is like my
bronzer because i did it just get on the
white now let's see no i think you're
good no wow
clean queen durable i'm gonna leave this
on so cute um so yeah noon o'clock
eastern time spritsociety.com check it
out really cute and
i'm sorry what was that
without
now without further ado we can get into
the pasta stores i just needed to get
that off my chest literally
um i do because it's on my chest spritz
society
okay first story dropped as we were
speaking yesterday because morgan
stewart yeah we did it and you ready to
read your ad because morgan stewart
announced on daily pop yesterday that
she is pregnant again nearly seven
months after giving birth this was so
unexpected so i think based on her
announcement and what she shared on
daily pop it was unexpected for her as
well but morgan stuart mcgraw and jordan
mcgraw are pregnant with baby number two
they welcomed their first child ro in
february of this year and now morgan is
expecting again she posted on her
instagram a picture of them um bumping
and she said maybe this baby will look
like me because ro looks so much like
yeah i guess i guess she does
yeah that's that it's crazy how much
babies look like they're like yeah it's
like always yeah no it's it's like
actually rude no i know but then when i
was watching yellowstone they shared
they were talking about that and they
said it's because like in the olden days
so you could like it was a paternity
test right right like
but it looks like they'd add so much
yeah but it's like
we did all the work this baby comes out
looking like their dad who did nothing
but like ejaculate nine months ago no no
it's
wild it's wild it's misogyny mother
nature's misogyny it is but there is
something that's also like cool that
it's like a natural dna test yeah i
guess
like like there's no denying that zach
shapiro is michaela's dad no no no i'm
like we talked about mikayla last night
how like i literally
i did something bad
you did something bad i gave mikayla a
chip and i guess like it wasn't the
biggest chip and all of a sudden she
started to choke and like honestly i saw
my life flash before my eyes i feel like
i i reacted in good i screamed for
olivia and i slapped her back and the
thing came flying out and michaela threw
up with my hands it was so sad that's
really sad but there was like a little
bit more to the story no i don't think
there's more at all actually i think
that's really where the story ends okay
i just like for i was there i was
definitely mutually michaela like being
annoying
like crazy but she was just like tired
and like okay so the thing is is that i
wanted her i took her onesie off so she
could like live free she's always in
these clothes i'm like michaela run free
in your diaper like you're a child like
i always see child's children running
alone in diapers commercials for diapers
in commercials i guess whatever i just
wanted her to be free she was at her
auntie's house i wanted her to relax a
little bit but i guess when she gets
undressed that's her signal that she's
going to bed and it was like 7 30 and
she was like started hysterically crying
that she had to go to bed i'm like girl
you're not even home like you're at your
aunt's house like you're not gonna
be going to sleep any time soon but she
was just relentless and olivia was like
give her something to eat like she loves
to eat i'm like queen so i got a pita
chip and olivia's like that one's too
small so then i got another pita chip
and it was bigger but i guess it wasn't
like huge
cut to makayla choking on it and i like
felt so guilty like after torturing her
like getting her out of her onesie back
in her onesie like she choked she threw
up like it was it was my fault for sure
but it was also just like how things
were meant to play out
okay that's the full story and now
you've shared it yeah i don't really
feel like i needed to share the whole
story you're just like
coming for me
no but it's fine i think the mutual is
essential to the story because she was
like crying like
she didn't throw up because i was much
scaring her
she threw up because the chip was too
small olivia said she didn't chew it she
just ate the whole thing in one bite
michaela's fine you know everyone's good
i'm just saying like it was really
traumatizing
for you for sure it is traumatizing i
remember the first time i saw like when
she was beavering her food and then she
like she goes red oh my god
traumatizing truly i hope that stuart
mcgraws don't have to experience that oh
right back to him look at us making
everything about michaela i'm so happy
for them their kids are going to be so
close in age which is so cute yeah and i
just love this like yeah bang them out
morgan just like bang bang bang well so
she shared on daily pop she didn't share
how far along she was because she had
said that um she didn't even know she
was going to be talking about it on like
announcing it on the show until like
that morning so she hadn't spoken with
jordan yet so she didn't like want to
share too much about like when the
babies do or whatever
but i think she's pretty far along um
she showed us her belly and
she said that like she didn't know for
so long because um she was like dealing
with postpartum like thyroid issues and
it just really snuck up on them and i
think that their doctor told them that
like they weren't going to be getting
pregnant at this time and so it wasn't
even a concern well it's a miracle it's
a miracle and i just love like
everything about this girl like every
decision she makes like i'm so here for
i'm like yes have another baby yes leave
daily pop like whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do i'm like i'm following morgan
stewart like to the grave no totally i'm
like another baby in four months done no
and you actually said after the show
wrapped like if you had asked yourself
like a year ago if you could be pregnant
at the same time any two celebrities of
course so now just to make it about me
as one second like to be pregnant at the
same time as kylie and morgan stewart
it's like
a
bounty the only thing that would make
this like more
like a hit the trifecta for you is if
like darite came out and announced that
she was pregnant no literally are you
like over there well
because i'm not like where i was last
year with her but i still like love her
but she's just not like my favorite this
season and that's okay of course but
still yeah no if she was in the trifecta
like that would be so exciting but like
i i'm so
i'm just feeling so grateful mm-hmm to
be playing this
for this opportunity look at me and this
opportunity
to be pregnant alongside these really
iconic women
and i just like and so many other
millions of other iconic women who are
pregnant at this very moment yes of
course but there's always millions of
pregnant iconic women um but just these
two are quite special to me and
i'm feeling really special and also that
leads into our next story
jennifer lawrence is pregnant as well
she's expecting her first bebe with
husband cook maroney
that's pretty much all the information
that we have her rep confirmed the happy
bed news to people on wednesday we don't
know like who what when where how but
just that
they are expecting it's very sweet i
love that like she lives like the most
normal life you know she's like a normal
husband
normal baby like normal normal role
and i don't know i'm just like obsessed
with jennifer lawrence like
she's never given me one single iota of
a reason like not to be obsessed like
she's so stunning her movies are so
[ __ ] good like name a bad jennifer
lawrence movie
i know you don't like silver linings
playbook but i wasn't even gonna say
that i think like what people would say
like it was objectively not good was
like that movie mother it was like a
horror movie oh yeah okay that's a good
one it was more like a rhetorical
question but okay um just like love
jennifer lawrence like and you know what
like not to flex like i did go to a
wedding that jennifer lawrence was at
and i feel like enough time has passed
now that like i can talk about it and
homegirl is so stunning and homegirl
like eats which just
really warms the cuckles of my heart
like she was eating and i'm like yes
jennifer eat
eight
now she's eating for two
so cute yeah so cute and this is another
one like
i feel special and like it definitely
feels nice to be pretty alongside of her
but
i don't have the same relationship to
her in my mind as i do to like kylie and
morgan of course not well i feel like
it's hard to have that type of
relationship with jennifer lawrence she
is like a celebrity who chooses to live
a very very private life yeah but i'm
sure she has stan somewhere who like
could choose if they could be pregnant
same time as any celebrity like they
would choose her
honestly like
no she is she really does such a good
job i'm sure she's like a really
balanced life like yes she's very
recognizable but i know she lives in new
york right so like there's just an
element of like you become very grounded
when you live in new york like nobody
gives a [ __ ] like get out of the way
give me that taxi like no one cares and
she also like doesn't have social media
so she doesn't have like fan accounts
like i don't know i feel like she's a
real but she's also like the most famous
woman in the world it's actually really
crazy she has such a
honestly like to get that that level of
fame but also probably probably i don't
know any of this for sure but like to
probably have that level of balance and
like normalcy in your life like
goals but don't you also feel like if so
she's like probably the number one
actress of our generation like a list
forever like if there's a serious movie
she's in it yeah don't you feel like if
that person were like also like on
social media being corny they wouldn't
they wouldn't be that person i don't
know but there's also a way to do it
like you know
who i recently followed on tick tock and
like you would think like this person on
tick tock
like
jessica chastain okay it's so good like
what does she post she's just doing like
you know things she's on set like she
got into i don't know what movie she's
playing but she has to do these awful
prosthetics that like make her look
heinous um like she has these huge jowls
so she did like a time lapse of this
whole journey and it's good i'm sorry
like it is good she's not being like i
think there's you know and i love her
i'm sorry but like jessica alba on tick
tock is the worst thing she ever did for
her brand like learning dances like it's
just
it's not it like for like i'm sorry like
a grown woman like just that's not what
we're doing i understand i think someone
who does a good job of being like so
taken seriously and
a queen of social media who said it on
three
three one two three
oh my god i didn't know if we were gonna
get it yeah i didn't know if we were
gonna hit it
um i think i love her social content i
think it's like very um
respectable but also
on point and like on message and
she's not embarrassing herself and she's
also staying relevant there was like a
joke on tic tac i'm trying to think of
who it was
there was a joke of like whoever runs
reese witherspoon's social media like
can you go over to this person's house
and help them out too because it was
like a celebrity it was so funny i can't
remember that's funny but like there are
so many celebrities in desperate need of
reese witherspoon's team yeah she kills
it on every platform like yeah truly
yeah yeah she does others not so much
oh it was camilla cabello
because hers is but you know camilla is
like a young person like she should be
doing better no but also she it should
be like more
just what is camilla doing today like it
doesn't have to be so curated you know i
think jennifer lawrence
might have a facebook page like i think
she like might be on instagram these
days no no
i don't know
but again like honestly if she were on
instagram i don't know if i would even
follow her i mean i just don't know if i
would want to be attacked by her beauty
like all the time my ready face enough
no she's not because i only really like
following celebrities who like you can
tell run their own [ __ ] but i'm sorry
she does have fan accounts
jennifer lawrence underscore jennifer
lawrence dot sexy picks let's take a
look at that ooh sexy pics yeah oh
that's not nice okay um oh wait jennifer
lynn lawrence j law
oh there's a race car driver wait
there is a verified person named
jennifer lynn lawrence but
it's definitely not jennifer lawrence
there's jennifer lawrence.act she has a
bunch of fan accounts and she should
she's the biggest model uh not model
actress in the world
and she really looks so similar to like
the girl we met when she was you know
starring what was that her first movie
winter bones
katniss no winter bones yeah but i
didn't see it
yeah then she was in that movie
about those two people who fell in love
but like they needed a green card does
anyone know what i'm talking about
and like she was the other woman and she
was like in this loft in this oversized
shirt i might just be making this up but
like
i remember being in theater seeing it
let me know if you remember what i'm
talking about i didn't see it
a little more pregnancy news pregnant
kylie jenner unveils her baby bump in
new york city she is stepping out and
giving us
pregnancy looks in her
white coat
uh she was impossible to miss with a
long vinyl coat left open at the front
to display her bed bump in a tight
clinging short dress she also wore a
huge smile for the outing with friends
but no sign of travis i just feel like
this is new territory for kylie i feel
like everything in kylie's life like
been there done that richest girl in the
world has everything but she's actually
never stepped out and about as a
pregnant person and it must be fun for
her to be having new experiences yeah
and it's fun for us pregnant people to
like see what kylie
how she's styling the bum and like
that's the that's the style like body
con i know you like hate it because we
were talking about that the other day
like if i was going to wherever she's
going which is like an actual party i
would wear that you would wear like a
tight dress and a jacket yes but i'm not
going to wear that on the toast every
day why not it's just like the toasters
deserve to see bump
they can see bump i'll wear like tighter
clothes but like i'm not going to wear a
dress i don't know i think it's lingerie
it's winter yeah no and like we
literally dress like slobs every day
like if you wear if you are a dress that
would be weird yeah like i'll start
dressing nicer in my pregnancy than i
did before yeah i don't know about slobs
every single day like a few days no for
sure for me sob every day not every day
and it's gotten worse and worse yeah
because but that's also just a sign of
the times but i feel like sometimes you
come in like looking so nice in one of
your blouses
like maybe i just i don't know i'm
feeling like not motivated to even look
like good i need to get an alpha for the
us open like i have to wear like a white
skirt you know yeah you do
where the [ __ ] does one buy like a
tennis outfit i have to go to like nike
yeah you just need a skirt you can even
like wear this spritz society structure
with like a little collared shirt
underneath a little
socks but then i have to like hit the
town afterwards
oh so it's like i need a transitional
outfit
yeah
my life is so unbelievably difficult
like nobody knows what it's like to have
my problems
well speaking of fashion i'm thinking of
fashion excited that kylie is out she's
bumping she's giving us everything that
we need and also we're seeing the bump
like in real time what does that mean
how far along is that person
are we on similar timelines it's not
that big
it looks like you after dinner oh no i
agree it's not that big no not at all it
looks bigger in the video
yes but like in the video we were seeing
skin she was obviously pushing her back
out a little like you know
yeah i feel like we could sync up
everyone is literally pregnant
what a fun time for me totally you know
because it felt like i missed that
window of like when everybody was
pregnant you know like literally every
single day on the show it was celebrity
bebe news to the point where we stopped
talking about who was pregnant because
it's just like boring yeah and i thought
like okay i missed the time to be like
in the popular pregnancy crew no like
you're never gonna be a plastic and now
i'm just in this like smaller trendier
crew and i'm so excited yeah no it's
more
exclusive
um you know what else is exclusive the
deal we have on frame bridge frame
bridge makes it easier and more
affordable more affordable than ever to
frame your favorite things without ever
leaving the house add a gallery wall to
your home office or send the perfect
gift from art prints and diplomas to the
photos sitting in your phone you can
frame bridge just about anything go to
framebridge.com and upload your photo
here's how it works they'll send you
packaging safely to mail in a physical
photo or you can upload directly to
framebridge.com you'll preview your item
online
in dozens of frame styles and gallery
wall layouts choose your favorite or get
free recommendations from their talented
designers the experts at framebridge
will custom frame your item and deliver
the finished piece directly to your door
ready to hang and instead of the
hundreds you'd pay at a framing store
their prices start at 39 and all
shipping is free plus our listeners can
get 15 off their first order at
framebridge.com when you use the promo
code toast they you can order online at
framebridge.com or they have stores now
a framework store you can work with a
designer in person if you're in new york
dc atlanta or philly boston and chicago
are coming soon get started today frame
your photos or find someone the perfect
gift go to framebridge.com
use the promo code toast to save an
additional 15 off your first order just
go to framebridge.com promo code toast
framebridge.com
promo code
toast yeah you guessed it
okay next story addison ray signs a deal
with netflix after he's all that success
she says it's beyond my wildest dreams
addison signed a multi-picture deal with
netflix meaning the streaming giant is
partnering with her to develop new films
specifically for her to star in she will
also executive produce the projects the
partnership comes after the success of
her acting debut in netflix's rom-com
remake he's all that which premiered
less than two weeks ago
she said getting the opportunity to work
with netflix was such a pinch me moment
and now to be able to continue the
relationship is beyond my wildest dreams
i'm thrilled to be able to collaborate
with this incredible team and i'm
excited to develop projects while
continuing to strengthen my skills as an
actress
i'm sorry like miss alison ray is the
queen of the world and
we are all her loyal subjects like
here's the thing get you a girl who
could do both and i'm not talking about
addison right i'm talking about netflix
netflix is so [ __ ] smart like maybe
some other streaming services would want
you know would be
hesitant about working with someone who
doesn't have a lot of experience but
netflix can get addison right and they
can get leonardo dicaprio for that movie
that just came out jennifer lawrence
laying order together like they can do
both and i love a versatile streaming
service yeah no i'm really glad that
this means that obviously he's all that
was so successful yeah we're not the
only ones who think it was creme de la
creme it was crazy so crummy so
cramming so beyond crammy and i'm happy
for actually sure like you know the
whole time they were like if this goes
well we can talk right and this went
well and they talked and this is the
outcome and it's also great for the
consumers because addison is a star and
i need more addison on my screen and
netflix is gonna give it to me no and
she's literally just like
a glamorous hollywood movie star like
it's so crazy and we were just talking
about she's on watch happens live
tonight which is crazy i will be
watching for the first time in months i
was under the impression that you had to
be 21
to be on watch live and maybe that's
only in studio
because of the bar
but you know what now that i think about
it like why couldn't you just be not 21
and not drink yeah no i just for as long
as i remember like i just know that was
the rule
maybe for the bartender or maybe that's
true because you would know bartender
rules yeah but also maybe since it's
virtual still like andy's there but the
guests aren't i mean the guests are
there but last night i watched
everything in new york last night i
watched ellen davidson and camille meyer
grammer
they probably couldn't get anyone better
but she were virtual though right they
probably couldn't get anyone better and
so they just like called some people in
but she's in new york with jason biggs
who lives in new york everybody's in new
york this week so he would not have
virtual guests okay okay okay okay okay
good good good but well i mean i guess
we'll see but there's no voice she's in
new york she was with the snitch
honestly i'm going to do something
really controversial
i feel like addison writes the next
jennifer lawrence like i'm sorry like i
think that i could see it
it's happening she's showing us oh and
you know yesterday when we were
recapping the demilio show we were
wondering like if addison kind of dealt
with these same
things
so i
think
part of the reason and this is again
just conjecture part of the reason why
addison like might be having less of a
hard time is i feel like everything that
emilio's do
like their reality show like it's all
very about them
in real life if that makes sense whereas
like addison is now doing projects like
music and acting that are like
it's not like a it's not something that
follows her every day if that makes
sense like she's just like doing
projects and then like can leave it at
the door where it's like they have a
camera crew in their home so this i i
think i understand what you're saying
they have some like a lot of what the
debilitaters are choosing to do like the
hulu show like they have a podcast two
chicks and their parents have a podcast
it's like if you don't show up you're
not working right where as i the goal
but they then they have so you need to
do it consistently every day social
tourists which is something they can
leave at the door and yeah it's like
they don't have to be on every single
day addison also is doing things that
like item beauty it's not something that
she has to do every single day it's like
a product line and i think the demelios
are doing some of that but they should
do more of it so that they can take
themselves out of the equation more
because the equation is hurting them
right and like when the equation is like
you have to post a million times a day
talk on your podcast once a week film
this reality show and it's also hellbent
on you and like your social battery i
think that that can be really taxing
where it's like addison's like she
filmed for a few months and then she
stops like it's probably exactly
projects you could leave at the door
yeah
so that was just like a thought
um
a great thought thank you a great
thought and now this really means
addison is a triple threat she's a
singer she's a dancer and she's an
actress and i would love to see her in a
musical maybe annie live
maybe annie live
maybe andy the sequel annie all grown up
and moves to hollywood like yeah no i
mean like she could have been grace
yeah she's like so young but also like
not that young in the digital space yeah
right like
i think
i don't know if she could play grace
because she's no i guess there's no like
there's no role for addison and annie
live there's no y.a role like
well maybe for the next live whatever
they do next yeah i could see her as
like a honestly
sandra d
been there done that though yeah yeah
yeah
one of their musicals could be like good
for
they did hairspray right yeah it's my
favorite musical she's such a penny
pendleton like
truly such penny pengleton but she could
also be amber von tassel oh cause she
just could do it all she's so versatile
she's a one-woman show starting amazon
right she does tracy she's link she's
all of it
yeah well i'm excited i'm really excited
for the content truly truly
he saw that was so [ __ ] good if you
haven't watched it yet go and watch it
and don't listen to people on the
internet who just like hate addison like
it was good
it was good stuff it was good mad good
mad good are you ready for our fifth and
final story and this one's going to
require a song because it's a
it's a music news story because it's the
final story
we need to find out what the next verse
is i'm ready to take this thing further
okay wait
what's the regular song the final
countdown
i don't we have to listen to it yeah i
don't think it might just keep going on
yeah like endlessly
this is the
song that never ends it just goes on and
on my friend
some people started singing it not
knowing what it was but they'll continue
singing it forever just because this is
the song that never ends it just goes on
and on my friend i'm sorry someone has
to stop you
so because the song does never end and
so someone's got to end it fine it's
going to be me
are you ready for the fifth and final
story
oh yeah i'm fine sorry cma awards are
here nominees 2021 cma award nominees
eric church chris stapleton and gabby
barrett are leading the nomination okay
just go quickly to entertainer of the
year entertainers i'm going to take you
through all the nominees and then we'll
vote and then our vote will mean nothing
absolutely nothing
nominees our entertainer of the year
eric church luke combs miranda lambert
chris stapleton carrie underwood
okay obviously like my heart is with
luke combs but when i think of actually
like who entertained me the most this
year
i don't think luke combs album came it
came out more than a year ago
who really seems what did we do this
year i don't know
it's a weird year because we're like on
year two of queue so this is like this
is this is from september this isn't six
feet apart like right
i don't know like i actually felt like
luke really deserved it last year
because of six feet apart and he had
released an album yeah honestly i don't
know what any honestly miranda lambert
probably she did release an album and
she has like a line of tequila a line of
clothes and she opened that bar in
nashville maybe randall lambert and you
know i stan actually
miranda lambert's album did come out
this year because she had that song that
we loved
how does it go bluebird yeah does it go
i don't know
[Music]
okay moving on single of the year famous
friends by chris young and kane brown
just came out like how can that be
single of the year the good ones by
gabby barrett beautiful song hell of a
view eric church also a beautiful song
one night standards ashley mcbride great
song i am obsessed
with i feel like i'm starting over by
chris ableton all really good songs but
like i don't know nothing about not one
of these songs really like sticks out to
me actually the good ones does yes but
like to me because that's like the most
my genre of all of these songs no but
like as someone who as people who
operate like in pop culture that song is
enormous it blew up on tick tock like
okay but like what was the country bop
of the year i wouldn't say the good ones
but i also wouldn't say any of these but
i also don't know what i would say i
mean like for me like it was ashley
mcbride like i just feel like
i haven't spoken about ashley mcbride in
a really long time and that's like
really upsetting because i stand at the
altar of ashley mcbride
and
i think she deserves to win okay even
though that song like was not the song
of the year the good ones was even
though i don't even like that song
no it's beautiful no also starting over
is so [ __ ] good
by christmas
is really good it's a hell of a view
you know what song i just heard on the
radio that i love and i can tell it's
really popular because it's in my
commercials now i'm noticing freedom is
a highway have you heard that song sing
it
freedom is a highway you need to listen
to me sings it it's two people i think
it's jimmy allen and
brad paisley okay i'll listen to it now
i need to find out to see if my memory
is worth anything
i only saw it like through the box on
the radio you know oh yeah so and
they're giving us nothing on the radio
jimmy allen and brad paisley good for
you okay that's really nice okay so i
don't really feel like there's a clear
winner here agreed album of the year
okay 29 by carly parse
dangerous the double album by morgan
wallin
heart by eric church skeletons by
brother osborne starting over chris
stapleton if we're just talking about
album
it's tough because you know i know he's
in a bad place but i have to say that
morgan williams album that he dropped
like right before he got canceled
was the best country album
in literally like 10 years like it's
it's a beautiful piece of work and i
don't know if they're going to give it
to him because he's so kind of
radioactive and i don't know if like
country music wants to be associated the
fact that he was nominated i think is a
big deal um
but i'm sorry like that was the album of
the year and then also just in terms of
sales like it was the most successful
out of all of those records country
without borders remember that cover so i
don't know where we go from here because
dangerous really was the album of the
year yeah but he's been like doing stuff
and coming back and he's very
debilitating himself yeah um
so and this is just the nomination for
album there they didn't nominate him for
entertainer of the year right right
which has to do with more than just
music yeah that's true no i'm saying if
we're just talking about this like
musically musically from a total third
party perspective with no additional
info in the matter
it was the album of the year yeah
song of the year
forever after all luke holmes oh that
was the song of the year sorry the good
ones gabby barrett hell of a view eric
church one night standards ashley
mcbride starting over chris stapleton
i'm loving the ashley mcbride respect
but i'm sorry this particular award does
go to luke homes forever after all that
was the song of the year yeah i agree
give them all to him give them all
female vocalist of the year that was fun
gabby barrett i think she'll win because
like she's so highly nominated no she's
like weirdly like killing it like it's
so random miranda lambert ashley mcbride
maron morris carly parse i think it's
going to be gabby brown you can't be
nominated like she's nominated for so
much no it's true like
she did that yeah male vocalist of the
year dark spently eric church luke combs
thomas rhett chris stapleton i mean
there's only one man for me no it's
honestly it comes but we have to think
about it like from uh
like a more real realistic perspective
like luke holmes has not released i
think he released like the bonus songs
of his album this year but he didn't
really release anything else
so i don't know how you can win that
award like i do think it'll probably go
to chris stapleton is my hair okay do i
have hat hair you did but now it's
better okay
that's just might be like one more
okay i guess we'll see what the academy
has to say the academy vocal group of
the year lady a little big town midland
old dominion zach brown band but you're
going so fast but then because i went so
fast because like these are always the
nominees there's only five vocal groups
in country music and they never include
rascal flats so and they never include
rascal flats and it's disgusting ages
even though acm honors
held an event at the opry did you see
this no in honor of rascal flatts where
all all these singers came out raelynn's
saying life is a highway was it
televised i saw it on tick tock i don't
know where you can watch it but it was
like a beautiful night honoring rascal
flats
why wasn't i invited no totally that's
[ __ ] sick sick
vocal duo of the year claudia and jackie
entree
vocal two of the year brooks and dunn
brothers osbourne dan and shea florida
george line maddie and tay it's brother
osbourne
yeah it's brothers osbourne um florida
georgia line is like not even together
anymore like yeah i mean dan and jay are
always doing great stuff but they come
in any year and i do brothers osborne
had a huge year brothers osborne had a
huge year and honestly like it pains me
to say this because i hate to be one of
those people but like the music that dan
and shea makes it's so good but it is
not country like i'm sorry i hate that
makes me sound like such like a like an
annoying like you know author country
it's but it's not like it's really pop
yeah like
i'm so glad you exist like that is like
a charlie booth song like it's not
country yeah honestly the more pop their
songs are like the ones that are super
poppy i don't like those ones same and i
think that their first album the one
that has um
19 you and me
yeah yeah no hold on just give me a
second nothing like you
i love
summer of 19 you and me
but they're
not this album but the one before it i
don't know how many they have but
it's so good like they
yeah
see discography
the album dan and che 2018
it's gorgeous like it's so [ __ ] good
but the next one is too i think it's
called like obsessed that was the most
the one before that 2016. obsessed yeah
they're both really good but like when
they were they were huge and then they
released dan and shay the album
there's yeah obsessed is probably my
favorite album they they're just like
not doing what they used to do for me
i'm sorry they're just doing it for
someone else no offense yeah yeah not
for you
okay last one i'm gonna do is the
musical event of the year which is
exciting by dirt by jordan davis and
luke bryan chasing after you ryan hurd
and marin morris drunk and i don't want
to go home l king and miranda lambert
famous friends chris young with kane
brown half of my hometown kelsey
ballerini with kenny chesney i'm going
to go drunk and i don't want to go home
because that was a musical event for me
yeah me too uh but the kelsey ballerini
kenny chelsea song is delightful
delightful and one more category sorry
new artist of the year
jimmy allen
ingrid andres feel like she's been
nominated i was just gonna say that
gabby barrett what
what she wasn't nominated last year this
is a joke no this i hate when like award
shows make no [ __ ] sense like record
of the year and song of the year like no
no no this doesn't make sense gabby
barrett is nominated she's been around
since american idol and i feel like last
year she was even nominated for female
vocalists of the year so how could you
be in that category and then the next
year be a new artist i'm in shock mickey
guyton and hardy
oh based on who's both really good
mickey gaiden and hardy are both amazing
that song one beer with hardy and lauren
elena is like one of my favorite country
songs based on who's actually a new
artist in this category i'm voting for
jimmy allen or mickey guyton is really a
new artist
yeah hardy's like kind of too
i'm unfamiliar
not i'm from i've heard of him but um
he's not on my playlist yeah um okay
well those were the country music award
nominations and i feel as though you
needed to know them i do i now feel like
a breast but it also just highlighted
for me how not abreast i am like i just
keep listening to like the same old
music and like some of those songs like
i don't know no i know before the award
shows i'm gonna have to do some recon
like usually they make a playlist that's
nice so that's nice i'll check that out
but no i need to do a little what are
the cma awards they're going to be in
like november are we going we haven't
discussed it we'll have to do it in our
strategy meeting
we have to go i know but like some of us
are pregnant no i know like what the
[ __ ]
we'll discuss it okay i guess i could be
bumping on the carpet that would be so
cute actually it would be cute but you
know and then maybe people would like
come and interview with us because they
feel bad like there's a pregnant woman
in heels like she came all this way
let's [ __ ] give her you know the time
of day the time of day yeah we can use
it as like a pity play okay just a
thought okay sure
sure if that works for you it does
um okay well today's uh
what it just makes so sad
so sad like the only way we'll get like
a good spot on the carpet it's like if
jackie comes like bumping if there's a
pregnant woman in heels totally doctor
sir could you spare a minute for my
pregnant friend
okay we're going to dive into tv recap
last night's episode of the real
housewives of beverly hills and the tv
recap is brought to you by betterhelp is
there something interfering with your
happiness or is preventing you from
achieving your goals betterhelp will
assess your needs and match you with
your own licensed professional therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help
it's professional therapy and it's all
done securely online the service is
available for clients worldwide you can
log into your account anytime and send a
message to your therapist you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as you
do with traditional therapy better help
is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change therapists if needed
it's more affordable than traditional
offline therapy and financial aid is
available betterhelps wants you to start
living a happier life today you can
visit their website read their
testimonials they're posted daily and
visit betterhelp.com toast that's
betterhelp.com
toast to join the over 2 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health with the help of an experienced
professional so many people have been
using betterhelp that they are
recruiting additional therapists in all
50 states and if you want a special
morning toast listener discount it's 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
toast thank you claudia okay part two of
the dinner party
ended quickly into the episode it did
but it was actually really shocking and
where do you where do you land like
who's siding on i'm on sutton side me
too and i also
it's just like the way that erica
spoke to sutton was so disgusting right
it's not even about the conversation and
sutton didn't even say anything like
other than just like a whisper of doubt
doubt which the whole world has of
course and the fact that that all the
women let erica sit there just like
penny
no petting that dog after like and get
away with it while sutton's like has to
leave so she doesn't get sued it's like
why didn't one person stand up and say
you leave erica yeah no you don't talk
to us like it was sociopathic behavior
with the dog at the end like how she was
just so evil and then like
like at some you know what it's just
like not a good look for erica because
at some point like we're all human and
if like even if you're fighting with
someone and they're like breaking down
and you're berating them like you let
off like you let go a little bit like
you stop going so [ __ ] hard and then
it's like eric has been painted in the
media as this evil woman who stole money
from people and then she's acting like
an evil like dr evil petting her petting
her dog and like you know
verbally assaulting people like she's
really not helping her case at all no
and i mean the
winner of the episode pk
speaking facts sucks and it looks he
spoke facts last week about the dresses
sorry he spoke facts this week about
erica and it looks like he's speaking
facts next week with maria
and i'm really excited for that
conversation not to be like but next
week looks good because it's going to
put kyle in the dab spot because she's
just kind of blindly defending erica and
i just don't understand what these women
are doing and i think the person who
bothered me most in this episode weirdly
was crystal
oh my god talk about
spineless
just like just because she thinks
sutton's awkward and like now she's
excited that she's just gonna be like
the enemy of my enemy is my friend yeah
like even though the enemy of your enemy
is maybe potentially a criminal no
honestly i every morsel of respect i had
for crystal was washed away the moment
sutton left the dinner party and she was
like crawling so [ __ ] far
up erica's ass it was pathetic i'm like
you're a grown woman you have children
and you're acting like you're in high
school like it was so lame
yeah i
i'm good on crystal now like she really
contributes nothing to the show
and now she's falling on the wrong side
of the pack especially when like
garcelle and sutton are the outsiders as
garcelle said like crystal you're an
outsider you can you know crawl all you
want but like no like no it was
loser-like behavior i was shocked at
like
have some respect for yourself like
you're just it's so blatant what you're
doing i don't even get her mo because
like she just hates sutton yeah and what
happened between them is so not serious
oh my god like who [ __ ] cares she
just hates sutton and she's just gonna
immediately jump on the ship of the
person who's arguing with sutton at
whatever moment which is just like so
losery like beyond especially because
like what you were fighting about it's
not even like it was real tings and
compared to what these two are fighting
about eric and sutton like this is
moronic and you know what erica keeps
like when now that sutton spoke up about
her doubts like erica just like is
looking at her like she was never a
friend but it's like you think back to
that scene like in the sauna when like
or like all those things that sutton did
for her when she first found out that
erica was going through a divorce and
like i think sutton is as good of a
friend as they come so like if she's not
allowed to ask questions
what like what are they doing and like
erica being like do you want to get sued
how dumb is erica first of all because
this whole time you've been treating
sutton like she's so irrational for
thinking she could be implicated in this
in any way just for being friends with
erica but then you're literally
threatening a lawsuit so it's like
you're
literally giving light to sutton's worst
fears and the concerns that she brought
up with you and also eric are like who
the hell are you going to see it like
you have no money no but what's even
crazier is erica was insinuating that
tom would sue sutton because of sutton
saying like she doesn't believe this
like natural
uh decline situation so it's like so she
should be worried no no it's like eric
are you in tom's corner right
no the fact that erica is just kind of
expecting everyone to sit around not ask
questions and believe everywhere that
comes out of her mouth when she's now
admitted that for the last few years
she's been lying about like so much
about her life it's so unreasonable of
her to ask out of people and i don't
even feel like doreen and sutton have
like gone hard at her or really asked
her the tough questions that they should
like i need someone to pin erica down i
was like where did that 20 million
dollars from ej global come from like
where did you think it was coming like
there's so many things they could be
asking so many things they could be
grilling her about and they're not
they're just like poking holes in her
very clearly like shitty stories and
that's sending her off of the edge like
it's so unreasonable who would want to
be friends with someone like that i
think that dorite
was good at the at the dinner party she
was you know
calling like defending suttonness but
like more than any of the other
fantastic four or anything obviously
garcelle like has sutton's back but it
was nice to see jerry sort of calling
out
and being like don't say stuff like that
i kyle was a disappointment completely
and throwing sutton under the bus and
then not understanding why something's
mad throwing sutton under the bus and
then saying she's doing it to help
sutton
gaslighting at its finest she was such a
bad friend to sutton and i'm so glad
sudden stood up for herself at that
auction place which is just like such a
weird subculture of like rich people
auctioning off oh and then like
whatever
um
then like she couldn't even understand
what sutton was saying like kyle knew
exactly what she was doing and she was
gaslighting sutton even more at that
auction place yeah like sutton i don't
think she's been too faced at all yes
she speaks a little more strongly behind
erica's back then to her erica scary
everybody does that okay and it's not
like she's saying two different things
and then at the dinner she and sutton is
someone who was extremely well-mannered
like in terms of actual matters yeah and
so
she went up to eric and asked if she
wanted to have a conversation erica said
no and sun's not going to have a whole
conversation at the dinner table at this
beautiful dinner because she has manners
yeah so her
taking erica's no i don't want to talk
to you and just accepting that and maybe
they'll talk another time isn't sutton
being two-faced no not at all like
i was so disappointed in kyle i think
she really thought and the way they say
it on the show they're like well if you
talk about it privately you have to
bring it up to the group otherwise you
know it's going to be out there and it's
like it means like if you say it on the
show you have to say it on the show and
it's like we're watching the show and
that's not how we feel no not at all and
this is like a much smaller thing but at
garcelle's party i feel like if i was to
read like i would have left crying me
too like everyone was just like
jabbing her like non-stop about the
timing and first of all she got
something done to her face because she
looked so different did you notice how
she looked oh no she looked different
but like
i think that she might have just like
recently got like lip injections or
something because she just looked like
like they hadn't settled yet okay but
whatever like ever like first betting on
who was gonna be last and then like
joking about how much she talks it was
just like they would non-stop like like
joking after reits expense and
everyone's like hysterically laughing i
would have started crying no me too the
thing betting on her being late like i
didn't find that offensive because like
she's the late one like that he had a
whole fight about it it was just the
first of like a million things that
happened that night like she's obviously
feeling like sensitive towards whatever
garcelle says to her but when she was at
the table and she started talking about
like her parents okay
and well that's how it's and then she
got into like the first night her npk
met and like i was really i thought it
was a really sweet moment and then she's
like you guys don't want to hear this
and i thought the ladies like they were
so mean about it like yeah when first i
didn't think it was a sweet moment but i
was just like i did i just i couldn't
have cared less it was like a little
cringy but the women like
i don't know i just feel like they like
she felt awkward and they could have
like done something to like make her
feel more comfortable these are supposed
to be her friends and they just were
like well don't talk until dessert like
shut up no and also like none of the
other women are speaking to each other
like anyone have anything interesting
you guys don't want to hear this do you
and like that the response is like no we
do even if you don't like at least she
asked of course no and you're just like
we're at a dinner party let's be polite
no we would love to hear your boring
story like you that's what you do yeah
but what it didn't seem to me like as
boring as some of the other things she
it seemed pretty boring to me like she
was just being like
like a boring old lady like you know
what i mean like but they are like when
i was dating pk i don't know i thought
it was cute
um the dinner party like had weird vibes
yeah i just like cannot stand like
serena like she's so far up everyone's
ass but like for the wrong reasons no
and like what was her pretending like
she wasn't at kathy hilton's dinner
oh literally like fake dementia like
amnesia she was strong and we said that
last week and she said it um but to act
like this is the first time you're
hearing like she needed a reminder like
you have no idea that erica said that's
not a threat that's a promise that was
phony as [ __ ] she had two drinks no
literally what the [ __ ] like
that was so weird it's like pretend
amnesia from like three seasons ago yes
that was really weird i feel like she
just like she doesn't want to have to
explain herself for being blindly loyal
to erica because it's such a
questionable decision yeah so if she
just gets drunk she doesn't have to
explain herself and she doesn't have to
get involved it's actually like a good
plan it's pretty good and then the next
day she doesn't have to have an opinion
on what happens she's hearing about it
for the first time and she just gets to
tell everyone like oh my god how crazy
was i throwing my legs in the air like
yeah oh but i thought the conversation
about erica's instagram like with pk but
then also kyle was talking about it i
thought that was really interesting
because it's true like
the victims who have watched you like
fly on your planes and
drive in your bentleys for years who
have wondered where their money are
monies are now
they're watching you like show your
vagina on instagram like it's not the
time erica no but it's it's the victims
but it's also like the public like you
are also on trial in the court of public
and like just like us like with every
word that comes out of her mouth like i
am weighing what to believe and what i
think happened and like the jury is out
for me about like where i stand on so
every bit of what erica puts out there
is like evidence being judged yeah yeah
and that's what you decide to put out
there no it's really bizarre it's like
she doesn't give a [ __ ] if people
believe her because the way she's acting
on the show like an animal
and her social media posts before the
show aired and even currently like
nothing is adding up like does she want
to be
well liked i don't know i don't know
either i think she thinks that if she's
like
eric and jane about it yeah and i think
some who was saying this i think yes pk
he was talking about like erica jane and
erica jordan i think
erica girardi is [ __ ] yeah that's
tom's wife yeah so she's leaning in
heavily to erica jane it's a good call
and so like she's like i don't know her
yeah this is me yeah
that's a good call you know but it's
like okay you're still the same [ __ ]
person yeah like how dumb do you think
we are like we know you're literally the
same person this isn't hannah montana
literally
it was just a very bizarre episode but
um
still so good yeah no really good um
but you know what i love it's really
frustrating when like things are
happening on the show and like it seems
like um all the cast members like really
think they know how it's going to play
out and they're all acting accordingly
and like everybody else watching it is
like screaming that you are all wrong
yeah you know like they probably think
that sutton it will never get another
season embarrassing herself no but the
audience stands with sutton and garcelle
stands with them you know what i thought
was a really [ __ ] fabulous moment
that i loved garcelle for at the end of
the episode where basically um
kyle's explaining like kind of taking up
defense for erica like you know i think
erica's mad because instead of sutton
like going around and talking to
everyone she should have just come to
erica and garcelle's like but you
literally did that to me last year like
you literally told everyone that i
didn't catch my check and i had no
[ __ ] idea like you should have just
told me yeah and she's like well i'm not
the bookkeeper i don't collect the money
and it's like that's not the point she's
like i thought we were past that not the
point like you say one thing and you do
the other like you're actually
hella hypocritical yeah and it's like we
can be past something like i don't hold
it against you but it could still be
used as
yeah totally well they just filmed the
reunion i hope there is accountability
but you know what after the you know
monique samuels of it all i have no
faith in andy no i do what's right and
after like all the [ __ ] well not that
much but the few times andy has spoken
about it on radio andy and like i've
heard it transcribed he's very much
giving erica like the innocent
treatment
and like he's not gonna be going hard
well i mean i you are innocent until
proven guilty and especially with erica
it's so unclear like what she knew
whatever but there are
legitimate questions to be asked will he
be asking them
they're such fair especially now
now that the reunion was what filmed
this month we know so much the
housewives and the hustler the 20
million dollars we know so much again if
we're not even gonna press on that like
then there's no point in watching no
i just don't know where we go from here
i don't know either because i don't
think eric is gonna be fired if she's
not convicted convicted um i don't know
how sutton will stay on the show but
like she doesn't deserve to lose her job
because she tried to do the right thing
no i completely agree i don't think
something's gonna be fired but how her
and erica can't like they can't actually
have dinners like that erica's never
going to forgive sutton never going to
speak to her again and she thinks she's
going to forgive during like they're so
close i think that they are they're
friends still and dory like didn't go as
hard as sutton even though sutton didn't
even go hard sutton was being so lame
like the fact that everyone's like oh
can't believe sutton said that i'm like
what did she say she was like a scared
cat like
yeah i don't know i don't know either
but
sutton and eric i don't think can stay
on the show because they won't speak to
each other and just like at garcelle's
dinner like that that doesn't work in a
group of seven women erica's just so
obnoxious like i'm reading the new york
times it's more interesting oh really is
there an article about you stealing
money from people in there right right
is there an expose or is that the l.a
times only
like she's so
cavalier and like condescending for
someone who has very questionable ethics
right now yeah like she should be acting
a little bit more humble in my opinion
yeah that's just my opinion
i would agree with you and that's our tv
recap and that was our show and that's
all we have for you today yes we will
see you tomorrow for the most wonderful
day of the week the most wonderful day
of the year it's called friday and it's
just so stupendous you guys don't forget
to get down we're so close to it i can
smell it thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning toast
millennial morning show where we deliver
the fast life stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching this on
youtube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i have
radio cast box all the places webby
listen podcast fine next morning chelsea
5 star
we are if you're still listening to this
episode congratulations you've made it
to the society season two and to let us
know that you've made it here go drop a
comment on our instagram our most recent
post an emoji of a tennis ball in honor
of claudia going to the us open
hopefully and head over to
sportssociety.com to get your merch it
is live now as you're listening so
come twin with us bye